Tyler: Do y'all know Jake Paul?
Mamrie/Hannah: Yes.
Grace: Uh, we're rolling.
*laughter*
*bouncing noise*
Grace: Hi guys, my name is Grace Helbig. If you did not know, now you know. Your life is different now.
Tyler: Ah, ah, ah
Grace: Oh my God.
Grace: I'm here with Hannah...
*generic applause insert*
and Tyler...
*generic kid 'ahhh' noises*
and Mamrie.
*generic male audience laughter*
Grace: And this is a fun video that I've already done with Hannah and Mamrie but Tyler, it's your turn.
Tyler: I love to have fun.
Grace: We are going- *laughter*
Hannah: Convincing...
Grace: Diane has helped me go back in time to some of your first Instagram posts
that the four of  us are going to look through right now and just do a general review.
Tyler: Okay.
Grace: Cause that's what friends do
Tyler: That sounds fun
Grace: Yeah, let's look back at some of Tyler's first Instagram posts all together, shall we?
Hannah: Woo!
Grace: We are starting out on July 18, 2012. What is this?
Tyler: So you can buy, in the Yearbook - I was the yearbook editor-in-chief
Tyler: And, in the yearbook your parents can buy you an ad.
Grace: Uh huh.
Tyler: And it says like a congrats, on gradulation... graduation.
Grace: Yeah
Grace: Let's talk about the photo.
Hannah: Can we ask about the expression?
*Laughter*
Tyler: Can I tell you something about this?
Mamrie: You - I would love to know everything about it sir.
Tyler: For my senior pictures, I had two days of shoots
Mamrie: TWO DAYS??
Hannah: Two days and this is the pic?
Tyler: One day with long hair, one day after a haircut. This is after haircut
Mamrie: I think I've seen the shaggy doo.
Tyler: The shaggy doo? Not the shaggy doo!
Grace: The cousin of Scooby Doo.
Hannah: Was it a shaggy don't?
Tyler: He betta shaggy don't.
Mamrie: So did most people do two days of filming or you specifically wanted both looks to choose from?
Tyler: I wanted both looks with multiple outfits and then for one hour of each day I brought my dog.
Hannah: Were you always... *laughter*
Grace: Oh my god!
Tyler: And look at the results.
Tyler: I look handsome, stunning, svelte.
Mamrie: Did you have any leaned up against barns and/or train tracks?
Tyler: I 100% had one against a pillar.
Grace: So we have...this is "opened the shower curtain this morning and found this," April 6, 2012.
Grace: We have Herbal Essences, some Suave, Petrol and a Bud Lite.
Mamrie: I'm a big fan and advocate of shower beer.
Tyler: Now I...
Hannah: Shower beer?
Grace: I thought this was a Mamrie Instagram.
Mamrie: Yes! An ice cold beer in a hot shower is one of life's tiny pleasures.
Tyler: I've moved on to a lime La Croix in the shower.
Mamrie: Well that's very grown up of you.
Tyler: Oh, thank you.
Grace: I like that Jen CK Roberts just said "NOT SUAVE!"
Tyler: Oh my God, a hater!
Hannah: What, are you thirsty in the shower?
Tyler: It's like a pre game. So you're getting ready to go out with the girls...
Grace: It's the best
Mamrie: So like the music's playing
Hannah: Really? Grace: Yeah, have you never done this?
Hannah: No!
Mamrie: Like everyone's getting ready. You hear the music
Mamrie: You're like I don't want to miss out on anything! I'll be drinking in the shower too!
Tyler: Just us? Just us.
Hannah: How many people are in the shower??
Grace: Ok, uhm..
Tyler: Awwwww.
Grace: Look at this fetus...
Tyler: I look so drunk
Grace: Baby. It says "this is what happens within 5 minutes of unveiling my world famous guacamole at a party"
Tyler: My world famous!
Tyler: I look like an actual baby.
Hannah: You do.
Mamrie: You look like you're so proud.
Hannah: What makes your guacamole so world famous?
Tyler: Um, the love.
*Diane laughs off screen*
*Laughter*
Grace: Diane laughed!! *more laughter*
Tyler: I had just shaved my head for the five-year anniversary of Britney shaving her head.
Grace: That's why you did that?
Tyler: Yeah
Hannah: Jesus.
Grace: Wow
Tyler: It's called love.
All: WOAH
Grace: This is March
All: T - G - I - F
Grace: Woah phonetically spelled out.
Tyler: This is Q bar. I know exactly where I was.
Hannah: Who was that?
Tyler: Who is she?
Mamrie: Who is she?
Tyler: I don't know her.
Grace: That's Hannah.
Tyler: That's not Hannah!
Mamrie: Is her shirt a tiny chicken dressed as a pirate?
Tyler: it is Hannah!
Grace: Someone said please do a "looking at old Instagram" video.
Tyler: Fine!
Tyler: We got, xoxo12
Hannah: So really you were just stalking Tyler's Insta and that's how you got your concept.
Grace: Big time.
*All gasp*
Hannah: Aw, simultaneously classy and trashy!
Tyler: Is this cater waiter night?
Tyler/Hannah: This is CATER WAITER NIGHT!
Grace: This was at Playlist in 2013...you got so held up trying to get to Playlist that you didn't get there till like midnight or something crazy.
Mamrie: I was still being cheap as f*ck, and I was like
you know what I will take the bus with everyone from the airport
and we had to wait two and a half hours before they took us to the hotel, so I got loaded.
I was like, "Do you have any booze?" They go: "We have like ten room temp beers."
I was like, "Mine, mine, mine! Dibs!"
Tyler: There was a moment you ordered food-
Grace: And Dan and Phil were in the room, and Dan and Phil had never met Mamrie before.
Grace: and Mamrie came in, like, in perfect Mamrie form-
Mamrie: So I took the cloche off the top of the...
Tyler: Not the cloche!
Mamrie: The cloche
Hannah: What's a cloche?
Mamrie: Excuse me Food Network, it's what- it closes...
*laughing gasps*
...room service
Mamrie: Put it on my head, put my ponytail through the hole and sang some songs for everyone.
Hannah: And what was that song?
All: *sings* Daddy was a cater waiter, didn't know what to do, so he put his little girl in the industry too.
Mamrie: *sings* Daddy was a cater waiter, didn't know what to do, so he put his little girl in the indust-
Grace: So Dan and Phil were just mesmerised by the unicorn that-
Mamrie: They were like, "What is she?!"
Grace: Here's our last Instagram photo. It is...tadaa
Hannah/Tyler/Mamrie: Awwwwww
Grace: Ew.
*laughter*
Hannah: It's cute!
Tyler: What is this from?!
Hannah/Grace: This is from, you-
Grace: We did our no filter show at...
Tyler: Awww  Grace: ...nerd mill I think..
Mamrie: For like, a hundred people.
Hannah: Our second show ever!
Grace: We were workshopping it and we had Tyler come in and play a guest role- what did you do in that in that show?
Tyler: I don't know what I did.
Grace: We did librarians and he like asked a question or something.
Mamrie: Does anyone have a question?
*audience cheers*
Tyler: So i have a question. I just have a quick question. So what happens when like a guy and like another guy want to-
*long censor bleep*
*audience laughter*
Tyler: And then like, do you clean that up after?
*more audience laughter*
Tyler: It was the first time I ever saw Youtubers on a stage like doing that, and like people coming and watching. I was just so proud.
Grace: I like that we're all individually wearing our own merch.
Mamrie: My forehead looks like Charles.
*laughter*
Grace: But look how far we've come.
Tyler: I know!
Grace: I mean, the lighting's slightly better now, but only slightly.
*train noises*
Grace: Hannah's got a show on the food Network.
Hannah: Ohhh
Tyler: Why do you say "oh"?
Grace: That could have been any emotion!
Mamrie: She turned into Don Knotts.
Grace: It's Mondays at 10pm?
Hannah: Mondays at 10pm, only on the Food Network.
Grace: Heeyy!
Tyler: That's so cool!
Hannah: I know, it's pretty fun!
Tyler: Look at how far you came! Little ol' you!
Hannah: Oh, well, you know. We'll see what happens.
*laughter* Hannah: I'm nervous...
Grace: If you like confidence like this, check out Hannah's Food Network show. Mondays at 10pm!
Mamrie: She 'Harts' food but not compliments.
*laughter*
Grace: Also we made videos on each one of their channels,
so they'll all be linked in the description below
go check them out because they were as emotional of a rollercoaster as this was.
Hannah: There was a lot.
Grace: Um, that's it.
*laughter* Hannah: or bye...
Grace: I don't know.
Tyler: Daddy was a cater waiter,
Mamrie: didn't know what to do.
Hannah: Oh oh!
Grace: So he put his little girl in the industry too.
Mamrie: We're basically Pentatonix.
Hannah: Guys, guest appearance, Pentatonix, us, doing that song.
Grace: Where?!
Tyler: Sure.
*laughter*
Tyler: Where?!
Hannah: Like at a Pentatonix show! Tyler's got a great bass!
Tyler: *deep voice* Thank you.
Tyler: *giggles* No, get outta here, no! Daddy wasn't this cater waiter!